[Aplausos]
[Música]
muchos nos habéis pedido que saquemos un
vídeo hablando sobre francia uno de los
países más ricos y a la vez con más
problemas económicos del mundo
a día de hoy francia es la segunda
potencia económica de la unión europea
pero esto podría durar mucho menos de lo
que algunos se imaginaría
su tasa de desempleo joven ya supera el
23% lo cual no es mucho si lo comparamos
con españa pero es que seamos honestos
la situación ahora mismo de españa no es
ningún ejemplo para que os hagáis una
idea hace 15 años el mundo entero
compraba a coche renault y móviles de
marca alcatel hoy en día estas
exportaciones han bajado a menos de la
mitad sus empresas parecen incapaces de
hacer frente a la competencia de esos
gigantes que vienen de china corea del
sur o incluso eeuu y alemania
[Música]
y su gobierno está endeudado hasta las
cejas como os podéis imaginar toda esta
crisis económica también tiene su
reflejo en la sociedad prueba de ello
son los resultados de estas elecciones
presidenciales de 2017 en las que
ninguno de los grandes partidos
tradicionales ha conseguido siquiera
pasar a la segunda vuelta la mayoría de
los franceses están hartos de su
establishment político y por eso han
elegido a un presidente que quiere dar
un giro de 180 grados a las cosas tal y
como se han llevado a cabo en este país
pero ahora la pregunta es cuáles han
sido las razones que han llevado a
francia a esta crisis en la que está
inmersa y lo que es más importante
pueden manuel macrón solucionar este
problema hoy vamos a responder a esta
pregunta pero antes vamos a ver un poco
de historia
[Música]
[Aplausos]
francia para los franceses tras la
segunda guerra mundial todos los países
de europa estaban arruinados francia
entre ellos la mitad del país estaba
destruida por los bombardeos y eso
incluye a las casas pero también a las
empresas las fábricas y los cultivos
por suerte el 'tío sam' estaba dispuesto
a ayudar generosamente a fin de cuentas
a eeuu le interesaba que europa
estuviera muy bien económicamente para
tener un mercado en el que vender sus
productos
y por eso el llamado plan marshall
supuso una inyección de miles de
millones de dólares para que todos estos
países europeos pudieran reconstruirse
pero esperad un momento porque cada uno
de estos países utilizo esta
financiación de manera distinta por
ejemplo el gobierno alemán desarrolló su
propia filosofía política a la que
llamaron gordo liberalismo o liberalismo
social y que combinaba el libre mercado
con las ayudas y la protección del
estado es decir que por un lado el
gobierno sacaba todo tipo de programas
sociales y de subvenciones pero por el
otro permitían que las empresas
mantuvieran su titularidad privada y
pudieran competir entre ellas
[Música]
el caso de francia fue muy distinto el
por entonces presidente el general
charles de gaulle no era un gran amigo
de la empresa privada y por eso su
teoría política el llamado dirigismo era
exactamente lo opuesto a lo que
proponían los alemanes
este gabinete no se dedica a hacer
propuestas sino a dar órdenes
así que charles de gaulle utilizó todo
este dinero que le llegaba de los eeuu
para nacionalizar prácticamente todas
las grandes empresas francesas
hablamos de fábrica siderúrgicas sector
eléctrico telecomunicaciones etcétera
incluso esos grandes gigantes del sector
automovilístico como peugeot renault o
citroën tenían al gobierno francés como
accionista mayoritario en una palabra
que podríamos decir que charles de
gaulle representa todo lo contrario a lo
que aplaudimos en visual político
[Música]
[Aplausos]
sin embargo tenemos que reconocer que
fue en esta época cuando francia entró
en los llamados gloriosos 30 en sólo
tres décadas los salarios de los
franceses se multiplicaron y estas
grandes empresas apoyadas por el estado
se comían el mercado internacional
[Música]
para que os hagáis una idea mucho antes
de que las empresas estadounidenses
deslocalizarán sus fábricas hacia china
ya había empresas francesas como renault
o michelín que montaban factorías en
españa donde los salarios eran mucho más
bajos para los que no lo sepáis yo soy
originalmente de valladolid y mi ciudad
experimentó un antes y un después desde
que renault abrió su planta y de hecho
es de esta época de donde viene esa
fascinación que tenemos los españoles
con nuestros vecinos del norte que en
los años 60 nos enseñaban a decir
[Música]
pero seamos honestos en aquella época
todos los demás países de europa estaban
creciendo al mismo nivel pensadlo bien
estamos hablando de los años 60 asia no
tenía todavía ninguna industria
importante latinoamérica sufría
dictaduras de todos los colores y los
países del bloque soviético tampoco
producían productos de calidad que se
pudieran vender en el mercado
internacional
[Música]
sin embargo francia tenía una importante
tradición industrial una sociedad bien
formada y sobre todo seguridad jurídica
y un marco político estable para las
empresas no sólo eso en 1958 todos estos
países europeos que ya se habían
reconstruido gracias al plan marshall
deciden formar una unión comercial que
sería el germen de lo que hoy en día es
la unión europea y en este momento
francia era el país con más población no
olvidéis que alemania estaba partida en
dos y eso significa que los franceses
tenían poder suficiente como para
negociar sus condiciones de entrada y
como recordaréis atrás de gaulle no era
un gran amigo de la empresa privada ni
mucho menos del libre comercio
así que utilizó esta posición de fuerza
para que francia mantuviera su dominio
sobre muchos sectores como por ejemplo
la agricultura
uno puede saltar y gritar europa europa
europa pero no sirve para nada y tampoco
significa nada
[Música]
si veis este vídeo desde españa estoy
seguro de que habréis oído hablar de la
política agraria comunitaria una
legislación que sirve para evitar que
los europeos podamos comprar productos
agrícolas al tercer mundo pero no sólo
eso también impone unas cuotas para los
productores que están dentro de la
propia unión europea es decir que un
ganadero polaco o español no puede
producir y vender toda la leche que
quiera se tiene que ajustar a unos
máximos fijados por bruselas pues bien
esta política es un invento de francia y
eso explica cosas como están
con una valoración base de 70 mil 400
millones de euros la producción agrícola
francesa líder a europa de gol consiguió
mantenerse en el poder durante décadas
pero el resto de presidentes que le
sucedieron mantuvieron este modelo al
pie de la letra a fin de cuentas durante
los años 60 y 70
francia estaba on fire así que si algo
funciona para que lo vas a cambiar pues
bien ahora vamos a verlo
mismas soluciones para un problema
distinto el problema surge cuando el
resto del mundo evoluciona más rápido
que tú ya que llegamos a los años 80 y
[Música]
el muro de berlín cae y china- se abre
al comercio internacional y nuevos
países como españa o grecia entran en la
unión europea y por supuesto también
quieren vender sus productos en el
mercado común en otras palabras a
francia le surgen competidores y eso
explica que noticias como ésta sean algo
tan habitual en los informativos desde
hace décadas
granjeros franceses furiosos han atacado
envíos de fruta y verdura española
debido a la crisis del e.coli los
productores españoles han bajado los
precios para cubrir sus pérdidas y ahora
son más baratos que sus homólogos
franceses y lo mismo ocurre en el resto
de sectores fijaros en esta gráfica que
representa la balanza de pagos de
francia
si os dais cuenta veréis que a partir de
los años 90 las exportaciones francesas
empiezan a caer paulatinamente y esta
tendencia es mucho más acusada a partir
de la crisis financiera
[Música]
os acordáis de los teléfonos alcatel
cuando empezaron a masificarse los
teléfonos móviles
alcatel era uno de los gigantes del
sector hoy han desaparecido en un
mercado dominado por empresas
estadounidenses chinas y surcoreanas y
este solo es un ejemplo de esa pérdida
de innovación que está sufriendo francia
hoy en día
y cuál ha sido la respuesta de los
gobiernos franceses a lo largo de estos
años pues mantener esa obsesión con
proteger a sus empresas del resto del
mundo por ejemplo otros países como
suecia también tenían a grandes
compañías como por ejemplo la
automovilística volvo sin embargo cuando
un grupo de inversores chinos decidieron
comprar esta empresa el gobierno no se
interpuso tenía muy claro que una cosa
son los negocios y otra la política
no podemos decir lo mismo de francia y
si no me creéis mirando qué ocurrió
cuando pep si intentó comprar danone en
el año 2005
y habló el ministro de trabajo dijo que
el gobierno hará todo lo que pueda para
evitar la compra y thierry bretón
ministro de finanzas defendió que hay
que proteger
danone sin embargo hay muchas cosas que
no cambian en francia- su gasto social
es el más alto de toda la unión europea
muy por encima incluso de los países
nórdicos el estado francés emplea a más
funcionarios que ningún otro país
europeo y además les paga bastante mejor
que a los trabajadores de las empresas
privadas
en otras palabras francia ingresa cada
vez menos dinero pero sigue gastando lo
mismo que gastaba durante los años
gloriosos y eso explica que su deuda
haya crecido hasta niveles insostenibles
pero esperado un momento porque ahora es
cuando las cosas pueden empezar a
cambiar
la revolución tranquila de macrón ya lo
sabemos una cosa es lo que un político
promete en campaña electoral y otra muy
distinta es lo que hace una vez llega el
gobierno pero hay una cosa que le
tenemos que reconocer a emmanuel macrón
su programa electoral era una ruptura
completa con ese dirigismo que ha
dominado la política francesa durante
décadas todos los analistas han tildado
a este hombre como un moderado incluso
un continuista pero realmente lo es
lo cierto es que tiene propuestas que no
se habían escuchado nunca antes en
ningún otro político francés ni de
izquierdas ni de derechas de trifón
program tu opinión queremos abrir la
competencia en los servicios ni en
sectores como los bienes de consumo y el
transporte
trainspotting son para que os hagáis una
idea en una campaña dominada por el
populismo del epen macrón ha llegado a
proponer la prejubilación de más de 120
mil funcionarios y sí ya sé que a muchos
esto os parecerá una barbaridad pero hay
que reconocerle una cosa honestidad es
decir cualquier otro político habría
enmascarado este tipo de medidas con
palabras más genéricas como reducción de
la deuda optimización del gasto o
simplemente recortes de presupuesto
mccrone sin embargo se ha ganado la
confianza de sus votantes haciendo
exactamente lo contrario de lo que se
supone que tiene que decir un candidato
en unas elecciones en su programa
aseguraba cosas tan impopulares como no
reducir la edad de jubilación vamos que
está claro que tiene un plan muy
concreto para reducir ese gasto público
y esa deuda pública que tiene francia
por otra parte macrón combina esos
recortes con una reducción general de
los impuestos que pagan tanto los
ciudadanos franceses como sus empresas y
además quiere lanzar una política para
impulsar la creación de pequeñas
empresas que innoven en otras palabras
macrón quieres sustituir este modelo
dirigista francés por otro más parecido
al de los países nórdicos o incluso el
de alemania en el que por supuesto el
estado garantiza unos servicios sociales
pero no interviene en la economía
privada es decir separación entre
negocios y políticas
pero ahora os preguntaréis realmente
tiene macrón poder suficiente para poder
sacar adelante todas estas medidas es
cierto que en francia la figura del
presidente tiene más poder que en otros
países pero aún así cualquier ley que
quisiera sacar en manuel macrón tendría
que pasar por el parlamento y quien
domina el poder legislativo en francia
lo cierto es que no lo sabremos hasta
verano este mes de junio de 2017 los
franceses van a volver a las urnas esta
vez para elegir su cámara de
representantes
y ahí el partido de marín le pen el
frente nacional tiene posibilidades muy
serias de convertirse en la primera
fuerza política que haría frente a este
aperturismo económico de macrón pero que
propone exactamente esa extrema derecha
francesa haced clic en este vídeo para
conocer la historia del clan lepén una
historia que incluye luchas familiares
tramas de poder y hasta conejitas de
playboy
pero ahora la pregunta es realmente
puede macrón sacar a francia del
atolladero tiene algún remedio esta
crisis económica francesa podéis dejarme
vuestra respuesta en los comentarios
[Música]
[Aplausos]
pero esperad un momento porque estos
acordes tan hermosos y melódicos que
estamos escuchando son la música de
tasmania ese grupo de grunge de alicante
en españa' que son grandes amigos de
este canal y que necesitan de nuestra
ayuda están participando en un concurso
para poder tocar nada menos que en el
spring festival junto a otras bandas
bien conocidas como love of lesbian y
para ganar necesitan conseguir un montón
de likes en esta foto que han colgado en
su facebook así que por favor haced clic
en el enlace que os he dejado en la
descripción y dadle a like a la foto que
no se diga que en visual polític no
apoyamos a los grupos de rock que están
empezando y también os tenemos que dar
las gracias a todos aquellos que estáis
haciendo donaciones a nuestra cuenta de
paypal nunca os las hemos pedido pero
nos están sirviendo para poder continuar
con este proyecto que es visual político
pero también para poder sacar nuevos
proyectos con los que vamos a sorprender
dentro de poco así que muchas gracias
porque todos vosotros
es posible y si sois nuevos y esta es la
primera vez que entráis en el canal
suscribiros para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones si os han
gustado este vídeo dadle a like y nos
vemos en el próximo un abrazo y hasta
pronto
[Música]
[Aplausos]